good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday post
toasterween we're still riding that high
hello ryan oh oops i mean jackie it's
hard to tell the difference we're so
simpatico and
irachiko and hypnotico but the ryan
energy is so underrated because he's
really like you know he's like that
loyal brother but he's also a [ __ ]
starter he's like very crafty gaslighter
and i really enjoyed my time as ryan you
know i give it all to toaster you do
once a year every year i leave it all on
these couches with my method acting and
it's not something that i have any
desire to do more than once a year but i
do love to give my all to the show and
everybody loved the episode everybody
loved high school musical four they
should definitely reboot that one ryan
and sharpay start a podcast i feel very
relieved like halloween is like a big
thing for us we always want to like top
the year before i feel so at peace with
our decision to do ryan and sharpay you
know you never know what's going to play
uh-huh and i feel like this huge weight
and now i really feel like we're in the
holiday season like it's [ __ ]
freezing today and yesterday like i know
everybody else was celebrating november
first like rachel parcell got her tree
up i watched her whole life mariah was
smashing pumpkins but yesterday for me
was still halloween because we were in
toast to win mood because of like you
know the scheduling
and now today is my november first like
if we had trees we would put them up
today bright-eyed bushy-tailed so
excited for the holiday season i feel
like i can really let it start to sink
in and that's how you all probably felt
yesterday and it's never too late to
feel like it's november first do you
think that it's an appropriate time to
start listening to the jackie ho ho ho
playlist i do i would say november
first is the appropriate time and
actually i know that i said i would be
listening to kelly clarkson's album when
it came out on october 15th but i
haven't listened yet because it just
didn't it wasn't the right time it
wasn't the right time and you don't want
to force these things no no no but now
you can start now i can start i need to
you know make a plan i want to you know
what i want to do maybe this is part of
like my nesting and maybe i've graduated
from chile how many chilies can you make
in one month i mean i literally made a
vat of chili and i was forced to eat it
for lunch and dinner every single day i
had for dinner last night too like it's
like enough i had chili for lunch
yesterday no and like it's a fun process
but like then i have all this chili
and i have to eat it no totally so i
think i want to try and bake something
that's good
so
i need to get like baking tins i don't
have baking tips even if it's just like
peel and stick or whatever they cook no
no i'm i'm gonna scratch you scratchy oh
and you know what i'm in the mood to
bake you're gonna like yuck my yums of
course carrot cake carrot you're kidding
that's sick and twisted
so unsupported why would anyone put
vegetables in a dessert like really i
don't understand i guess if you didn't
want to be supportive then you would oh
for sure yeah no i'm not supportive at
all like i was going to come over and
eat your delicious treats but not
that okay well then you make like a i
don't know like a a pie or like
literally anything else that's like the
one pastry i've refused to eat i don't
know i want or also i don't [ __ ] with
banana bread i've never made a banana
bread i i'm just having the itch for
carrot cake to make carrot cake like i
don't want to make a pie necessarily
seems like a lot of you know cutting of
apples i feel like okay fine why don't
you make like homemade cookies like from
scratch
you could just do size and bake
they're so delicious okay i just feel
like there are other things you can make
we'll take suggestions i'm feeling like
so good about my decision so
dew will come over you guys do is here
today i haven't seen him in so long i
know he was literally yelping as we left
the door like he knew exactly where he
was going i couldn't even get his leash
on he was like
it's been a long few weeks for do but
now he's back in the saddle he's back to
work he's going to help you and empty
make a carrot cake
and okay thank you that's
that's my plan you'll be fine
walk it off oh my god choked my own
saliva
i'm sorry what were you saying i wasn't
listening i was gasping for air just
talking about my
excitement for my plans of making carrot
cake nesting now i'm kind of like maybe
i should bake something the great
british brick the great british bake off
yeah what are you gonna make like
something fattening and delicious yeah
maybe make like a chocolate cake or like
maybe like
maybe that like we would like layer like
a real cake
you know sorry i'm like excited not just
like
from the box in a pan yeah no like i'd
make two different cakes layer them
frost them that's what the carrot cake
is but yes for your cake honestly i just
really don't feel like i can do any of
this while i'm still in my apartment i
can't explain it like and i have no
plans to to actually get out but
you know when you reach the end of your
time in an apartment and you refuse to
do anything
that's where i'm at i refuse to put my
clothes away
olivia came over and she's like what the
[ __ ] happened to your apartment and i'm
like
it was
no boy now it was outgrown yeah and
she's like everything's broken i'm like
i know like why would i fix it i don't i
don't plan on living here for much
longer but you'll be living there for a
long time you won't be seeing the snow
by christmas just stop barring some
christmas miracle you might not be
seeing this now by christmas i actually
saw brian last night he was asking me
and actually
seeing brian's apartment he just got a
new place in the city really invigorated
my he will not only see the snow he will
see just like the girl who cried new
apartment so and i think we're all just
sort of no i don't think so at the end
of our road so i was telling brian why i
was having not serious you're not i look
every day you're not a serious no but
what brian said to me he's like i told
him exactly what i was looking for he
was like you literally need to double
your rent like
and he's like just do it i'm like it's
not about what you can spend it's about
what you're willing to spend on rent
like it's just it's such silliness you
know
yes it is because you're like flushing
money down the drain you'll never get
that money back but your home is also
the most important part of your life so
both arguments could be made i already
thought my budget was way high and he
was like i was like embarrassed to tell
him
you're just not a serious girl
can you stop saying that like when
you're serious i'm [ __ ] serious just
because like i don't you haven't found
anything doesn't mean i'm not literally
i spend every waking moment in my life
on street easy okay
i do
i think i found a building i want to
live in okay that's a good start yeah it
seems reasonably priced there's not a
lot of outdoor space but of all the
things i'm will i want in my apartment
that's when i'm willing to give up it's
cold now like yeah and i got all hot and
excited during the warm warm months but
you're never going to use it ever ever
because most people don't i had a
balcony at my and u.s previous
department
yeah no never so i think you can say
goodbye to that yeah no there's certain
things of non-negotiable but that's
definitely one i could just toss aside
great that's progress that's getting
serious by the way i'm also willing to
toss inside a second bedroom like that's
how [ __ ] nuts i am okay okay i'm
serious i'm committed and i i really am
upset that you don't think i'm committed
i need you to prove your commitment how
by getting an apartment i would love to
yep no i okay you seem serious now you
were really dilly dallying there i don't
have covert i'm like still choking from
that experience but i think i'm okay now
okay let us know keep us posted 100
words up
um so we have a great show for you today
we have dear toasters it's tuesday we've
got the stories
nothing was on tv last night for our
show but i did watch the new episode of
succession and after binge watching
everything
it really is frustrating to watch them
episodically i don't know if i'm gonna
go on because i'm not invested anymore
like i'm just you know it was a good
episode though it was a good episode
because kendall was such a [ __ ] loser
it was an embarrassment and you
absolutely love to see him getting his
ass handed to him but it's a bed of his
own making oh my god i'm still girly
girly girl i'm really sorry if you can
just move my mic for one second so i can
just like let it out oh let it out over
there
so if you walk to session i am still
team logan don't come for me i mean
you maybe if you had a [ __ ] company
that you built you would know what it's
like to run a company and not just try
and steal one when you get a little
bored no kendall is the biggest [ __ ]
loser of all time i cannot believe not
only are like there are people out there
who are a team candle i'd say the
majority of viewers are team cameras
75 of my audience is team kendall which
is shocking i did a poll yesterday too
and it was similar results and i'm just
like what because like
you ha i just can't like honestly like
it's
first of all lest we not forget spoiler
alert
he's a murderer
second of all he's just like such a
loser like he's not even he's not
innovative he's not smart he's not a
killer he doesn't have instincts any
time he's ever [ __ ] something up for
the family it's because he had to go to
someone to ask them what to do and he
couldn't keep
something private because he couldn't
make the decision for himself he is not
a leader he is nothing of the sort no
and he doesn't actually like want to
make a change that's what she shivan is
like the one who i think has like the
strongest moral compass and like she's
the one who's just really gonna do the
thing that best serves
society and like the victims and when
she went to kendall to be like you know
we could really make a change from the
inside like he doesn't care like that's
not why he's doing this no and like he's
not like a whistleblower for the right
reasons in the beginning of the show
when he talks about like his plans for
the company in the five minutes where he
had control and he talks about like all
the lifeboats and how they're gonna be
like disrupters and innovators and he's
using like all these buzzwords that
don't mean anything i'm like you are a
phony he is aussie media that's him yeah
that's him he has no real ideas like
nothing that generates income like the
one acquisition that he brought in was
like such an epic failure
no it's a no for me dog totally um
we also dear toasters today which is
just always an exciting day to give out
delicious advice
and the past five and i think that's it
right no tv no nothing else nope
um just theo's presence radiating
positive energy throughout all of our
bones yeah happy to see the dew here and
so i think without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
manscaped think your holiday spread is
good it's time to give thanks to the
manscaped performance package 4.0 inside
you'll find their lawnmower lawn mower
4.0 trimmer the weed whacker ear and
nose hair trimmer the crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer briefs and a travel
bag to hold all of your goodies so if
you are looking for something to get for
your significant other a brother
a dad during the holiday season check
out manscape they've got all the best
men's grooming products they have great
accessories like travel bags they have
great um like skin care they have great
electronics ben uses the razor all the
time if you have a dad with a hairy nose
or boyfriend who just want to like send
the message like hey trim your ears
manscaped will do it all for you so it's
really a gift for you and for them
um
also for the gifters out there manscaped
is sealing the deal with two free gifts
from their performance package 4.0 the
man skipped boxers and the shed travel
bag so if you get that package you'll
get boxers and the travel bag which ben
has the travel bag it's very elegant
it's really big it packs really nicely
um
we also have a discount 20 off and free
shipping with the code toast at
manscaped.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with the code toast at
manscaped.com be thankful this holiday
season for the best gift of all from
manscaped your balls will thank you okay
our first story a little young hollywood
flame has fizzled outer bank stars chase
stokes and madeleine klein break up
after one year together page six can
confirm that the couple has broken up
chase and madeline are not together
anymore a source shared it's no secret
among those who know them that they
broke up a second insider revealed that
things got rocky between chase and
madeline in september and they were
openly talking to friends about the
breakup in october yes i it's like if
you're a sleuth you've known this yeah
they both start on outer banks which up
until now was a great show because the
two main characters were in love on the
show and in real life and now like
everything else i expect the show to go
downhill because
john b and sarah's
relationship like love for each other is
what holds the show together otherwise
it's just two warring tribes really and
so if we don't sense that deep
connection anymore the show i'm sorry
it's not going to be the same no you
know what like this isn't good like
not to be like a downer a pessimist but
like the show will ultimately be
affected by this um but again like how
many great seasons do you get out of a
show you know we got two really great
seasons maybe we should just be grateful
for that not that the show's gonna end
you know what maybe they already filmed
the third one before the break that
would be great but i don't think so
it's possible because it's a very like
summery show so i think they do have to
film in the warm weather that is true
and season two came out a while ago
who's good too and they probably knew
they were gonna i think there's a chance
so you're saying there's a chance
there's a chance we got one more good
season well so she has been like
gallivanting being a gal about town
going like paris fashion week i saw she
was spotted like dancing with ross
butler
from um like everything teeny bopper
so i think that's a cute couple i mean
it will be really interesting because
you know those two got famous so fast
and we're dating each other the whole
time so they've never been out in like
the celebrity dating pool and there's so
many fabulous young men and women in
hollywood for them to choose from and
honestly we could get down about this or
we could also get excited about the
prospective partners of both of them
they're both so good-looking so famous
young hollywood no that that is exciting
i just feel like they were a couple that
it's like that i get more excited about
them as a couple then their potential
ships that they could sail off into
because you know they could wind up with
people we don't know people we don't
like people we don't know for sure you
know that's worse yeah
yeah no so i mean we'll see like i i
mean i don't watch anymore but the thing
that feels most similar to me is like
betty and joghead like are they still
dating once they broke up in real life
were they still dating on riverdale i
haven't watched the new season yet so
it's so [ __ ] spooky um i will let you
know okay because like that's
interesting to me like
and i think that they have to still be
dating on riverdale the show really
doesn't work without bughead because the
writers made the decision that bughead
was going to be ending right right not
betty and archie not even varchy like
it's going to be bughead you can't go
back on that path later so like i'm just
trying to think like in like in recent
history like what other shows i mean
high school musical the musical the
series also comes to mind but they did
stay together dating in the show while
also not being together in real life
olivia rodrigo and joshua basketball and
there's weirdness you could feel it the
show is like
not that big of a deal right so i think
it'll be very interesting to see what
happens hope like if they really did
break up amicably i don't know how
amicably you could break up with someone
when you have to like go to work and
kiss them like it's weird it's so weird
hollywood is such a weird place when
stuff like that happens and you know
what i always think about do you
remember that guy from desperate
housewives who played
edie's husband dave he had like the icy
blue eyes he's like this random soap
actor and he will not kiss women like
that's why he's like not that famous
he's only gotten so many roles where
people have agreed to not let him not
make him kiss his fellow actors or
actresses because he's married and i
think he's like kind of religious and he
our son went
no he like doesn't want to because it is
like a weird it's a weird situation when
you're married and then you go to set
and you're kissing other
other people
most actors and actresses just do it but
he had
drew a line in the sand and said that he
wouldn't which i really respect but i
was watching the brittany murphy
documentary and like her whole career is
like rom-coms etc
and one of the last movies that she did
like her husband crazy pants um
wouldn't let her kiss anyone on set and
like when she got the part that was
obviously part of the part and then she
like told the director no i'm not going
to be kissing this after that gave him a
long hug or something and the director
then went to crazy man's husband was
like we're going to recast it right you
guys like continue this nonsense so
crazy pants allowed it so obviously like
you would never want your husband to
like not tell you to do something but if
it's a personal choice i think it's a
nice choice to make yeah of course of
course but when i hear people in
hollywood like talk about it because
they get asked all the time like it's a
very natural question like you're in a
loving relationship and you're literally
filming like naked titty sex scenes like
is it not weird is it not cheating and
every response i've heard from
celebrities like they normalized it so
much and i guess if you do it enough it
does become normalized but i'm sorry
like there are just some things that are
not normal and that's one of them like
literally consistently making out the
same person you're on a soap opera
you're on something and then literally
going home and having sex with your
husband like sorry there's something
weird about it i agree i agree they're
gonna tell you it's not weird but it's
just it's weird and there's also this
new thing where like in more like art
films during sex scenes the people will
actually have sex just to really get
they're lying it's very very very rare
and it's very niche art i could see it
becoming more popular in hollywood and
i'm just saying like things are [ __ ]
weird most sex scenes like they're
wearing bits on their butt and it's like
you know it's more mechanical it's more
of like a a stage thing but still like
your bits are on there but it's like
it's bitsy central it's busy on muffling
it's bit on bit crime it's nuts okay
yeah so it's like hopefully they don't
have too many bits in outer banks where
they got to be bits on bits oh totally
but it's not really that raunchy of a
show it's for kids
um it the relationship is steamy yeah
but we've never seen them have sex like
we haven't no okay but that's good ever
yeah it's like really a kids show with a
lot of violence yeah and like a lot of
story lines that don't [ __ ] make
sense and a lot of people acting like
morons more runs
are you ready for our next story
really just wanting to take one moment
to acknowledge i'm very sad about this
couple like
yeah me too they were like so cute and
they seemed so in love so it's sad
on to the next no and you know what
it really makes you think it really
makes you think like
you shouldn't date your co-stars or at
least until like after the show no you
know what i think yes obviously this is
a possibility you go two seasons hot and
heavy and then the breakup is
gut-wrenching but it's worth it for i
think like the time that they must have
had together getting famous together on
this show together playing
romantic partners in real life they went
to the bahamas i think that that was
probably like an amazing two years that
you can't you know you have to live you
can't let the fear of heartbreak stop
you from following your heart but when
you think about like the greatest shows
like most successful there was none of
that like nobody on friends dated nobody
on gossip girl dated like nobody on
serena and dan dated in real life yeah
okay for a very long time okay so
nothing oc
summer and seth dated yeah but like the
oc
no it's the opposite
no i don't think it's the opposite i
think that there's something to
not like i think riverdale like is trash
that's just because you don't like the
show no but like ever since like all of
that fizzled out it's like trash all of
what fizzled out
bughead you stopped watching along
before that for sure but i just think
like i think there's a weirdness that
you can sense and like i think it does i
think it does like affect overall shows
like not even that one specific example
i think that for sure
so it's okay for movies but not for
shows yeah movies end like
a
series of movies
that's a difficult that's a different
question i mean were
kristen stewart and edward together for
all five movies i think so cause that's
like the perfect example of like it
working out yeah for the best and most
of the time it's probably not going to
work out but i think it's worth it for
those moments of magic you can't just
say you can't just live in fear claude
no of course not but i'm just talking
about like it's a place
watcher
would it be best if like everyone you
just let sleeping dogs lie no as a tv
watcher it's worth it for the good times
and then yeah you know what but all
shows get bad no matter what happens in
the relationship that's also true so at
least we have those special moments i'm
i'm really here for it and for these
kids like this was a lot once in a
lifetime
you know i'm sure they'll be telling
their grandkids about this stuff
you know what show had like a lot of
weird [ __ ] going on i mean obviously and
still to this day like glee
people were dating there was also like
weird [ __ ] going around on that show
like in general outside of the
relationships yeah
so
so i think i stand by i really do stand
by my statement like please don't take
your stars but i agree like it is this
like once in a lifetime like
thing
and i say and i'm happy for them i'm
happy for them for the time that they
had don't be sad that's over smile
because it happened madeleine and chase
i'm just like trying to think of one
example where like a couple stayed
together the whole show you know
but i can't
hmm we'll figure it out someone will let
us know okay next story cardi b will be
hosting the 2021 american music awards
and she is so excited on tuesday the
rapper was announced as the host of the
upcoming amas
producers and abc confirmed in a
statement shared with people she said
when i received the invite to host amaze
i was so excited i'm ready to bring my
personality to the ama stage i think
that she'll be great yeah me too she's
very funny very personable the amas are
not like a serious award show in terms
of like knowing like oh he won an ama
like he's not the grammy so it's all
just like a fun
yeah thing and she's going to be
excellent at it it reminds me of like
kelly clarkson hosting the board awards
it's like a good award show it's a great
place to you know see if you got the
chops
and i think cardi will have the chops
that's why i'm i'll meet you for this i
think she's a star she's throwing
through but she also has like such a
great personality that i think it's
going to radiate i think this is a
really really strong choice it's just
crazy that like she probably is among
the most nominated like and she's also
working the room so this is what i was
gonna say and i would love to hear your
take on this do you think it's a step
down for like a celebrity like to host
like i was always under the impression
that the host is always less famous than
the people in the room the nominees but
that hasn't been the case as of recent
like jojo cat hosted the bmas obviously
kelly clarkson so i don't know it's like
this weird new thing i don't know if i
like it i don't know if i like it either
and it is weird when it's like you're
supposed to be the person that's
celebrated and you're hosting it's not a
step down if like you're very much
choosing like cardi there's no question
it's not like she doesn't have to climb
like this just seems like a fun project
for her so in that light it's not sad
yeah
but it is weird don't you think
i like i prefer the days when like
comedians or people on the up or on the
down would take the job
and like they're significantly less
famous than the people they're they're
discussing yeah but cardi b is going to
be like introducing and just talking
about her peers right but that also
makes it fun it's cool i'm not i'm not
not here for it
i don't think i'm here for it but the
idea that like these celebrities are
just taking over the hosting jobs when
it's like there are hosts there are
comedians there are people who are like
this is their job right well that's the
other thing it's like i feel like we
talk about that a long time like if
you're a trained host or like you go to
school for journalism like you want to
be an on-air correspondent like the
eligible jobs for you are just getting
fewer and fewer because they're really
being taken by influencers celebrities
people who don't have traditional
hosting experience or training yeah i
wouldn't even be offended by influencers
doing it because some influencers like
it's their dream too right to be juliana
you know no not offended i'm just
i'm just it's interesting to point out
that like the job like when i was in
communications classes like every girl
like what's your dream job the next
giuliana rancic everyone and now it's
like good luck
yeah whatever happened to laverne cox
she was doing she was the next juliana
right like yeah but red carbon season
hasn't started i feel like we report on
that a long time ago no we reported on
it like at the end of last red carpet
season and now it hasn't like it comes
back in like january february so okay
we'll see her then
cool are you excited for
laverne oh yeah
i don't really like
i like watching red carpet shows
um
but i don't really notice the
interviewers and actually i think that's
good they're not meant to be noticed
they're not meant to be noticed so we'll
see how laverne does yes okay next story
a little bravo liberty romance news
summer house stars carl and lindsay are
sparking dating rumors i mean this is
just weird cause like if you're watching
the show now it's like who she's like
obsessed with austin yeah lindsay
hubbard and karl radke had fans in a
tizzy on social media over the weekend
after posting an intimate halloween
photo dressed as baby and johnny castle
from dirty dancing they held each other
close while mimicking the iconic movie
poster
so there's like
whispers that these two are dating i
don't i saw a video of someone from
entertainment tonight like fully asking
them and they like they said like no we
don't have anything to say but like
they're obviously dating okay i don't
know the history
i don't think they're i mean i don't
know the history did they ever date on
summer house no
but i think people have just been like
rooting for them like quietly like she's
she's
okay you know what i actually when i was
watching winter house i had this thought
she's like the type of girl who says
like she's not like other girls like she
loves hanging out with the guys like her
guys her best friends and so she's
really been best friends with really
every guy forever um and that includes
carl but carl's in this like new place
um
he's sober you know his brother passed
away last season he's been through a lot
and he's in this like new i think
really fresh good headspace and the
thing with lindsay and i i actually
really like her when i first started
watching the show i didn't get her she's
a lot and i fully get her now and i
think she's hilarious but i don't know
if she's the best person for carl right
now because she's still this like crazy
album and you see her on winter house
she loves to drink and that's why we
love her and she's hilarious
i don't know if it's the best match for
him in the current headspace that he's
in interesting
interesting do you think like she could
be in a different head space than where
she was on winter house of course we
never know yeah because it was filmed a
while ago yeah
so i don't know i mean i think it's
really interesting i think it's great
for the show i think with the absence of
vanderpump rules
i think summer house is really turning
into like the young show on bravo and i
think what they're doing with some
winter house is great i think all of
them dating within their group is only
even better for the show yeah all rise
ships think tides yeah agreed okay so we
ship
um
i need to know more i do but also i
don't know these people personally like
sometimes we talk about reality starts
like i know them in real life i don't
know these two at all i've met carl i
don't think i've met lindsay um
but you know what i'm cautiously
optimistic okay cool so maybe like a
little canoe that might take us like
maybe um what's it called the boat that
takes the dinghy no there's a more
official name
fricker
the boat that takes you to a yacht yeah
a dinghy no
uh okay hold on
what's the name of this that takes you
to the yacht
tender tender by the way it didn't even
come up i just remembered it yes
from below deck yes exactly i hear that
that
and you probably wouldn't know him
but the captain from the very first
season of below deck i think his name
was mark he passed away i saw that he
was only 65 that's so sad very very sad
really sad news sorry um are you ready
for our next story before you dive in i
just wanted to let everyone know that
this next story that's obviously amazing
i'm not sure what it is but i know you
would just have it's incredibly
important amazing tastes and stories is
brought to you by nuts.com the best kept
secret of savvy snackers across the
country and now newcastle customers are
getting 10 off so our entire studio our
pantry is filled with snacks from
nuts.com obviously they sell nuts but
they sell a lot of different candies
dried fruits it's so good if you're like
so over the regular just like chips and
pretzels like you want to get some
artisanal snacks they have amazing
shipping so it comes super fast all the
stuff is so good um it's just like
different and also they're so holiday
friendly like all these things these
rich chocolates and trail mixes like
perfect spread for the holiday season
if you haven't tried nuts.com now is
your chance to check them out and get 10
off the simple and convenient way to
have nutritious delicious nuts dried
fruits flowers and grains and so many
other high quality foods delivered
straight to you they have over 4000
products to choose from we love the
white chocolate toffee cashews and the
um honey sesame sticks they're just
things you will never see at a grocery
store they're so much better more
inventive and a great way to just like
stock your pantry with good stuff for
yourself and also the holiday season if
you have people over they are unbeatable
quality they deliver fresh products
fresher than the supermarket and the
delivery is super fast because most
orders ship the same day
um so if you are new nuts.com customer
you want to get 10 off your first order
text toast to 64 000 that's text toast
to sixty four thousand to get the ten
percent off your first order of nuts.com
toast to sixty four thousand terms apply
available at nuts.com terms great
next story our queen jessica simpson is
celebrating four years of sobriety with
a candid photo showing an unrecognized
yeah unrecognizable version of herself
so on monday
jessica simpson shared a photo of
herself from four years ago her first
day without alcohol and detailed the way
she felt the day she decided to begin
her sobriety journey now if you read her
book then you are familiar with this day
because you are that's where the books
it's the center of the book it's the
center of the book you know she goes to
the kid's school that thing and with
them she's very triggered yeah and so
you know where she was at and she said
this person in the early morning on
november 1st 2017 is a recognizable
version of myself i had so much
self-discovery to unlock and explore i
knew in this very moment i would allow
myself to take back my light show
victory over my internal battle of
self-respect and brave this world with
piercing clarity it was really like a
heartbreaking post and that picture i
mean when you read when you read the
book basically the whole book starts at
this day the day she decided to get
sober and then she goes back in time and
forward in time but the the main kind of
hook of the book is this day and you
picture it in your head of course when
you're reading the book and to be honest
that's exactly what i pictured it
looking like yeah no me too i can't
believe it's been four years that's
amazing yeah i'm so happy that she's
like still in this wonderful place and i
just want to use this as a reminder um
if you haven't read her book yet you
absolutely have to absolutely have to
one of my biggest regrets is rushing
through it because it was just like so
big and long and i wanted to talk to you
about and i remember just like rushing
through the end
take your time it's a long book so like
you have to read it all in one sitting
it's so good it's full of so much for
soft you love pop culture there's so
many john mayer nick lachey eggless
celebrity stuff that's just like
gorgeous but it's also this like really
honest and like deep book about trauma
her childhood is so interesting honestly
when celebrities write about their
childhood like sometimes i skip right
through it oh my god she grew up in like
the bible belt she had these crazy
stories about her dad's church like it
was really good like i loved every part
of it the john mayer stuff and the bible
belt stuff yeah i loved every part of it
i read it in like one or two sittings
and i loved crazy but i loved reading it
that way like i couldn't put down like i
was so immersed in it yeah and
it was a very long and like it's a very
well written book so it's not like
something you just breeze through it's
like every page like there's sense
there's a lot of meat to it but it was
so so good and i would say before her
book came out i wouldn't have called
myself like a jessica simpsons and she
was just like you know one of the pop
stars so you can use my birthday buddy
so i probably you had a different
connection but you don't have to have a
pre-existing connection with her you
will feel connected through her journey
and i just want to say i often think
about how like one of the pivotal moment
like moments of her career was a chili
cook-off
yes but in a really negative no in a
very negative way but like
chili was there for her yeah no that's
true
um and she talks about that moment i'm
sure you guys all
you know what's so funny it's like you
remember certain things so like there
was this picture of her wearing these
high-waisted jeans um she had gained a
little bit of weight and they splattered
it everywhere like big fat girl chili
cook-off they were so [ __ ] mean to
her and you remember and you're like oh
yeah she was like big and then i
remember like after i read the book i
went and looked at the picture and like
she's so normal looking like it's not
it's so crazy how you remember things
and how everything was sensationalized
and she was a part of that group like
we're seeing it play out with britney
and
those young uh mickey mouse club
misika mooska mickey
how like they were all just like pitted
against each other and
i thought one of the most interesting
parts of the book is like how jessica
simpson during her time as like a pop
star
compared herself to the britneys and the
christina's and like had to do things
differently because they were all like
the same
they came from similar backgrounds they
were all blonde they were all pop stars
it's really such a good book and i loved
it
loved so that's your daily reminder oh
and you know we didn't talk about
yesterday how um when andy went on the
today show to announce the real
housewives of dubai he was actually
doing press he has a new book coming out
but it's not like one of his andy cohen
diaries quotes yeah it's quotes from
it's like 100 365 days for 365 quotes
woman i love or whatever i'm good yeah i
i loved andy's books like all three of
them are on my top i give them all five
stars i would have loved another book
yeah no this is not that no this is like
a coffee table book
yeah like real how like true true real
housewives fans but it's not coffee
table book sized it's kind of lentil oh
so it's like something they sell it like
urban outfitters i still don't watch
what happens live no but you could have
books on your coffee table or like
display books that aren't
massive astoulin books yeah
um i don't know if i'm gonna get this
one yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
yes
it's the final story
[Music]
for the morning
actually just reminded me i spent i was
so busy yesterday like writing out so
much material for my show tickets
available at growth no job.com tour and
working on a project that i think i can
just tell everyone like i have a new
song coming out
um pretty soon so i don't know yet
but soon and it's so good like it's just
we really leveled up this time like i'm
really excited everyone's gonna love it
obviously it's like riddled with toast
inside jokes and it's so good and i'm
really proud of it so it's so exciting
have you recorded it no so it's just
been completely written and like built
out and i'm recording it next week so
i'm really excited exciting are you
recording it here
no i'm oh in new york yesterday in this
studio no not unless you want jackhammer
on the ones and twos you know it sounds
pretty good i'm not like a full-fledged
studio in new york but last time like
you had to go to l.a yeah yeah yeah i
i'm going to la next week for a wedding
so um maybe you'll head up the studio
there i asked the producers i'm like is
it easier like it doesn't matter because
with covet everyone recorded songs
remotely that it's actually like easier
to record a song remotely with like a
producer in your ear like that's what
i'll be doing okay cool yeah very
exciting well our fifth story is some
more epic music news that everybody's
looking forward to
the tracklist for adele's album 30 is
here and it includes a duet with chris
stapleton chris stapleton is having the
year of collaborations literally the two
biggest albums of the year coming out
like this and next week adele and taylor
swift and they both have chris stapleton
on them yeah okay so here are the names
of the songs which just like if it were
anyone else i wouldn't care but because
it's adele i just need every nugget or i
guess if it was taylor swift you would
care yeah of course yeah and if it was
kelly clarkson i don't care for sure we
actually did this for kelly clarkson we
went songwriting and we did it for
taylor swift okay cool when she did love
her at least we're consistent yeah
one strangers by nature oh that sounds
like uh
uh you know you tell me the song lyric
and i'll tell you what i think it sounds
like okay and then and then in a week
we'll go back and listen okay okay too
easy on me obviously let me think
i think it'll probably sound like you
know
[Music]
adam um to guess i don't think so that
doesn't sound like her
three my little love
love
love bug yeah something like that cool
four cry your heart out cry
that was good five oh my god oh that's
tough oh my god oh my god oh my god you
guys that's it for sure
six can i get it
okay i think it would be like
no actually i can't i can't see this one
in my head you know i'm very i'm a very
visual person i can't see it seven i
drank wine
oh i could see it being like a very
british bob like i drink wine
wine wine wine something like that yeah
very amy winehouse vibes okay that's
what that was by the way amy winehouse
yeah no you guys don't that was still
clogging it was twisted we didn't just
cut to amy winehouse eight all night
parking with errol garner interlude okay
so i don't even know what any of that
means i think it means no lyrics it's an
interlude
oh
that's cool so you're off you get this
one oh like oh wait all instruments
oh yeah that's probably what it sounds
like nine women like me not to be
confused with the little mix song no but
by the way that sounds like it's gonna
be the best song on the album i'm a
woman no no no
a woman like me
yeah that's what i think and i hope
someone doesn't match up with women like
me
are you laughing at me all any of this
little mixed drama because i'm on little
mix talk
so i i was following yet it's crazy it
is crazy it's kind of quieted down yes
it was like two weeks or maybe a week or
two ago the girls obviously broke up
jesse nelson released every time i
talked about little mix drama like
everyone comments like who
so what yeah so i was like okay let's
educate the people okay so little mix is
the most epic girl band on the planet
right now yeah they really are they're
literally the best
band ever they're so great they're from
x factor they were four girls we have
perry leanne
jade jade and jessie a year ago you
might remember when you commented who on
our
posts that jessie left the band and
claudia will tell you she saw it coming
i did the other three i did see it don't
just breeze past that i did see it okay
but that's not the we have to get to the
point the other three seem to have like
a really great sisterhood sisterhood two
of them were pregnant at the same time
two of them just gave birth and so the
other three carried forward without
jesse they never looked back it was
giving very much zane energy like the
band was unaffected by the departure yes
and also just a fun fact perry and zane
did used to date for a very long time
right before he started dating ggs and
that's just something that you should
know yeah no that was actually like but
it's not jeremy
she was the biggest girl band on x
factor uk and then in the uk he was the
biggest boy band x factor uk and then in
the uk and then they were dating it was
actually like perfect yeah but it's not
the big it's not jeremy into the story
no just a fun fact so dead so the three
girls are little mix they put out an
album since they they're not letting
them slow them down nor are they letting
pregnancy they're doing the most the
[ __ ] most and they even have like a
new album coming out that's like i think
it's been how like 10 years of little
mix or something and the album is like
old hits greatest hits yeah so [ __ ]
good so but by the way part there were a
lot of rumors when she left and before
she left that there was a big divide
between jessie the girl who left and
leanne who is the one woman of color in
the group okay and jesse had been
accused a lot of times on social media
of black fishing of appropriating black
culture and apparently they had you know
spoken about it within the group and
they really kind of tried to
speak to jessie in a
polite and calm manner about this whole
thing and jesse was like having none of
it so then her new song she just
released her first single yes bad bad
boy nicki minaj is on it yes it's jesse
nelson her first single and the music
video came out and it was kind of like
everything that people had been upset
with about jessie nelson about coming to
fruition in this music video like it's
very
provocative in the sense where she's you
know really dressing acting
looking like she's black fishing and so
it just kind of blew up on social media
especially on tick tock that's where i
learned about everything
um
and it's like
i didn't know it was such a big story on
tick tock oh because i like was seeing
it because i'm a little mixed sand but
it wasn't everywhere no little mix talk
like it's everywhere i've seen the whole
music i think it sounds better than
little mixtape it's so good and now
they're doing like performances like
comparing with jessie without like how
much better it is without jessie like
the little mix fans are shady as [ __ ]
and it's it's really like been a wild
story back to the story though so then
the girls who are still in little mix
like unfollowed jessie then jessie and
nicki minaj nicki minaj has had jessie's
back through this through and through
they went on live together yeah there
were tweets and nikki was just like
going after leanne who is the woman of
color in little mix and it was actually
like really not cool of nicki minaj i
didn't like that they were being mean to
leanne because like whether wherever you
land on this like leah's a really nice
girl like yeah she's a p p jowl she is
precious gem of woman she's a pressure
channel she's a pea jolly precious
gemini little mix so it's just been like
this crazy thing because when she broke
up when she left the band it wasn't like
the biggest it wasn't contentious they
were like jesse and she had was citing
like mental health concerns and like
that the band was no longer good for her
mindset and and all the women were like
yeah we were the fans were supportive we
were like as long as this means
continued little mix right you won't
hear people so like when a person leaves
a girl band like it's either destructive
camilla cabello
or not zane and jesse like you could
always tell when the person is leaving
if it's going to ruin the band yeah zane
was like 50 50 because zayn was like a
lot of people's favorites um but the
band i think was better without him yeah
um camilla obviously like there was
going to be no fifth harmony without
camilla um but jesse i think i think we
could have predicted that the band would
remain intact yeah if not better
sometimes you get better when you trim
the fat yeah and also like if you don't
want to be here we don't want you yeah
yeah we only want people who are
interested in little mix like right so
if i think if perry or leanne left it
would have been destructive
yes yes so that's the latest on little
mix yeah
ten hold on oh we're still doing this
hold on
no that was very giving me very much
broadway that was giving me like hodor
hodor dummy that was separate i think it
was more broadway it was very adina
menzel it was my lower register and it
was really hard to do
11. to be loved oh
to be loved i'm thinking very like you
know
tony bennett okay
12 love is a game
love is a game
i don't know i'm just making [ __ ] up at
this point i mean what were you doing in
the beginning no at the beginning i was
really kind of like connecting with my
internal musical spirit oh wow i'm just
making [ __ ] up bonus tracks
bonus tracks
wild wild west oh that sounds good
sounds so good yeah for uh can't be
together
i'm done guessing by the way okay that's
fine and then the last one is easy on me
with chris stapleton oh you're lying
guys everyone
oh i didn't realize that's where he was
everyone also i'm sure you saw that um
the special adele's like one night only
is being filmed at the griffith
observatory not kensington palace and i
can't even tell you like how
disappointed i am i'm sorry but it's not
my fault like it was a really good guess
something was filmed at kensington
palace people are saying it's taylor
swift now i'm just saying that's what
people on the internet are saying so
listen to none of it but i just like i
even if the special is like the best
thing i've ever seen like it won't be
good enough because it wasn't what i
hoped but i am very much looking forward
to it
i guess
but still like the disappointment i had
no expectations before and
um it's a lot so yeah he's on easy on me
so we already know what that song sounds
like so it'll be cool to hear a
different version and with the red
re-recording obviously we know the
song's on red already but there are
bonus tracks that she's never released
and chris stapleton is on one of the
bonus tracks so we don't know what song
is what it's going to sound like
interesting we know easy on me already
very very cool easy on me is aging
gorgeously like it's just getting better
and better with every listen this is
going to be a great month for music
everyone yeah both holiday and
non-holiday holiday and miscellaneous
and i think we have a lot to look
forward to yeah especially because we're
about to do deer toasters
which is our advice segment you guys if
you're ever looking for advice from your
two favorite gals on anything work stuff
relationship stuff
toe fungus scotch it down
email us dear toasters
the deer toaster segment is brought to
you
by papa and barkley they understand
wanting the absolute best for the people
that we care about so they are the best
cbd company i want to say they're
award-winning they have solutions for
pain stress sleep and everyday wellness
and their and unlike less effective cbd
brands they have an unmatched clean
chemical free whole plant process with
proven results so the whole company was
started
from a powerful homemade bomb from papa
papa and barkley um
and so if you are experiencing pain i
gave actually the um the bomb to my
father-in-law who has really bad back
pain and he said it helped tremendously
if you have pain topical pain on any
part of your body i would really
recommend getting into cbd we've been
talking about cbd for a while and papa
barkley is a great company their cbd
relief bomb delivers hours of comfort
with simple plant-based ingredients in
an at-home use test with over 300
participants users reported a 40
reduction in daily discomfort in just
one week of using the bomb they also
have the award-winning cbd oil the
relief drops is their fastest
metabolizing daily wellness option for
easing daily stress discomfort and
supporting good night's sleep
papa and barkley is on a mission to
improve lives through cbd in its purest
cleanest possible form
go to papa and barkley.com
slash toast for 20 off your first
purchase that's 20 off for new customers
at p a p a
and b-a-r-k-l-e-y
cbd dot com papa and barkley cbd.com
slash toast for 20 off papa and barkley
cbd.com
toast
thank you for that claudia are you okay
i just snuck off really quickly because
i have my glucose test
oh diabetes yeah pregnancy and i have my
drink with me like the sugar drink that
you have to drink but it needs to be
refrigerated and i just remembered so
when's the test
after this i drink it like when we wrap
and then an hour later i got the test
what is it like a needle blood
but you have to drink like the sugary
drink that should be chilled but i i
forgot to chill it are you going by
yourself yeah you wanna come with you
yeah what time
uh one okay i'll call it one i'll move
it
okay should we lunge first
no i can't eat no you're lying oh i
can't eat for an hour i don't think i
can come okay
okay hey god and jack hope you guys had
a spooky halloween it was so spooky it
was it was beyond spooky i wanted to
write in about this very first very
first world problem i've encountered i
want to preface this by saying i've
never been one to i'm sorry i've never
been one to split a plate at dinner or
swap clothes with my girlfriends or
sisters so what i'm about to tell you
guys is very triggering for me okay
one of the wa okay a month ago sorry i'm
like having a hard time reading and
speaking
a month ago we got a party bus for my
husband's birthday one of the wise got
soaked on the bus i'm assuming from
spilled beer but it was never soaked was
like a new word for drunk yeah but it
was never disclosed as what the wetness
was from she could have peed her pants
for all we know the couple lived five
minutes from us and rather than going
home it was nearly 1am they wanted to
continue hanging out with us so this
wife demanded i'd give her some pants to
wear so i found some spandex workout
shorts for her to wear they stayed too
long ended up getting a huge fight with
each other and leaving without her shoes
lol this girl got into an uber without
her shoes
the next morning they had to pick up
their car and the shoes and didn't bring
my shorts back which i was thankful for
like please wash them before you bring
them back but here we are a month later
and still no shorts her husband and my
husband are very close and they see each
other every week she and i are not close
and i only see her on holidays and
outings what does one do her husband
literally comes to my house every week
she didn't want to send them over with
him any time this past month i can't
help but wonder where are my shorts is
she regularly wearing them as if they
are her own are they being stashed in a
drawer somewhere have you girls ever
encountered something like this will i
ever see these shorts again it's not
even short season anymore so i feel like
i would come off petty if i just texted
her and was like hey can i have my
shorts back clearly i'm not wearing them
anytime soon but truly where are they
sincerely a shortlist toaster
okay i mean if this were me i really
can't relate because if she had like
unidentified liquid all over her and she
guarded my shorts like and she was
borrowing anything i would have given
her something that i actually didn't
want back something i've been looking to
get rid of so i wouldn't have to go
hounding her down even when i let people
borrow stuff like like i never would
give away like my nicest things if you
come to my house and like you need a
sweatshirt and you leave with it i am
assuming i'm not getting it back
especially if it's like a crutchety pair
of biker shorts like please keep your
crotch
and leave she had those unidentified
fluids on them plus i just want to say
she is obviously very drunk there's a
chance she got home shoeless woke up the
next morning in these shorts no shoes
has no idea where these shorts are from
and is just moving on with her life yeah
i think we need to
you in particular
need to part ways with the shorts and
and it's a lesson like if someone's ever
at your house you offer them up a
sweatshirt shorts anything like
you are giving someone something and at
least this is how i perceive it
without the intention of getting it back
yeah i'm giving it to you permanently
like it's yours now yeah i mean you
could if you really want them back you
could ask for them back i just wouldn't
want them back like are you dying for
them can you just get another pair like
what would you really wear and spandex
shorts you know that touches a lot it's
area material it goes in places and
stuff and i would you really wear them
again like is it worth asking for them
back honestly i think sharing biker
shorts is like sharing underwear i
totally agree do you even know if she
was wearing underwear such a good
question she was so drunk we should no
if she was soaked wouldn't she have
taken off her underwear
you could run a pair of underwear
through a washing machine six times and
i still wouldn't put them on if somebody
else had put them on
yeah
yeah there's just some things that we
don't touch yeah we don't share maybe
this perspective will like make you
realize like you don't even want them
back that's what i'm hoping for if you
still want them back because of the
principle because you're not a sharer
which i also understand
yeah just ask for the mac there's a
chance she doesn't know where she got
them but i would recommend just
saying a prayer say goodbye to the
shorts they're not yours anymore yeah
goodbye shorts have a good day
all right next up hello jackson claude
love you both and seeing the growth of
the toast also congrats jackie on a
little camper
long time listener first time writing in
i need your advice i broke up with my
boyfriend of two and a half years in
august it was mutual and we ended on
good terms we still talk every now and
then but we've established that there's
no future for us as partners back in
january of 2020 he bought us these the
sorry
in 2020 of january 2020 he bought us
these pretty leather and gold tiffany
matching bracelets as a promise to spend
our lives together classy he lost his
towards the end of our relationship but
i still have mine here's where i need
advice do i keep the bracelet give it
back to him or sell it it's a nice 1400
bracelet i still have the receipt and
the box to be honest i'm leaning towards
selling it because i will never wear it
again due to it representing a promise
that no longer exists and it's not super
stylish lol i don't want to come across
as ungrateful or disrespectful as that's
not my intention so what would y'all do
would love a toaster who kind of wants
to cash in on heartbreak i mean if you
don't love the bracelet and you're not
going to wear it then definitely sell it
if
it's just a matter of like do you want
to keep it or not i don't know i think
that there's two things i would love to
like with this fourteen hundred dollars
if you sold it secondhand you maybe
would get like eight hundred you get
like about half and then depends where
you're selling it they might take a cut
right like once you boil down whatever
the final number is let's take 600 like
i don't know your financial situation
like would that really really help or
would you remain on like 600 is great
because i don't know i know right now
it's like fresh but i think it's nice to
like collect things from former lovers
like you know when you're 80 you're
telling your grandkids like yeah i used
to be this hot [ __ ] look this man
bought me a 1500 bracelet if you don't
need to sell it i know it's kind of
tough right now but like throw it in a
box full of mentos and i just think it's
like nice to keep things that
once meant something to you yeah i agree
with that i do agree i was just gonna
say like if you enjoyed the bracelet i
would say keep wearing it even though it
doesn't mean what it once did i don't
think she enjoys it she doesn't she said
it was unfashionable which is quite
quite um
but i agree if you don't need to sell it
you could always sell it down the line
if you need to but
it is nice to keep mementos from
relationships past especially since this
seemed like it was a very serious one
yeah and it's just i feel like maybe
you're thinking about this now because
like the feelings are still fresh and
you just want to like get rid of all
mementos but i don't know there's
something to be said about just keeping
burying it in your closet keeping a box
of things that remind you of people who
used to love you yeah it's not like he
you know cheated on you you broke up
admirably i would keep it
yeah i agree but you have to wear it and
you could always then sell it if your
decision to keep it is bothering you or
you need the cash yeah all right this
third one is an update finally we are
hearing from a girl she said i wrote in
earlier this summer regarding my friends
constantly talking about babies anytime
we're together well here's the update i
confronted my friends on day one of the
girls weekend which was a terrible idea
i don't remember this one to you no okay
maybe she'll remind us my friends felt
personally attacked started crying and
couldn't understand why i was feeling
this way so needless to say i slept with
one eye open and i was afraid they would
murder me with a breast pump or
something of the sort the next morning i
heard all the girls in the dining room
eating breakfast and i went up to
apologize as soon as i started one of
the girls interrupted me and
apologized smash we talked about what
you said last night and we agree with
what you said we never realized how
constantly talking about our kids would
impact you i was shocked long story
short after a few mimosas and wine tours
the gal pals were back together and
reminiscing about the good old days and
to everyone's shock our friend announced
that she was pregnant
can't wait to listen to this can't wait
to listen to
this birth story and her baby's
milestones for the next year sign the
best auntie who has her friends back so
i guess if i recall it correctly like
this girl is one of the only girls in
the group who doesn't have kids and it's
like [ __ ] in a way like can we talk
about something else so she told
everyone of course the mamas were
offended at first but you know what they
molded over and this is the lesson here
and this is what we're always saying
communication is the key saying how
you're feeling if you feel like it's
worth it get it off your chest yeah
sometimes it's not worth it so yeah it's
knowing whether or not it's worth it and
that's
that's where the magic lies that's what
we do here yeah and sometimes like you
think you're so right and then you hear
it from another perspective i remember
this the last time we did your toasters
a girl wrote in like thinking she was
100 right but when we are totally
unbiased third-party non-affiliates and
it's like we probably are leaning
towards taking your side just know that
like we're ready to take your side so if
we are saying like you're wrong we're
saving you all the trouble of like
making a big stink about something and
your friends are like no but you're
wrong yeah but you know what this girl
was right she was entitled to her
feelings and everyone worked out in the
end and that's what we call a happy
ending here at the morning toast you
love to see it and speaking of happy
endings that is the end of our show that
is the end of our show also it is
election day so make sure you get out
what is it primary no midterm mayoral is
it november oh my god it's okay it's a
legit election day
it's so weird like election day when
it's not tuesday in november oh my god i
literally thought this was like a
midterm
we're gonna have a new mayor
oh my god okay i'm going out to vote
when ben was here we were talking about
it by the way i just got like so like i
just had an existential crisis like i
did not realize it was november we've
been talking about a new mayor for so
long you guys please go out and vote
like well regardless of whether they go
out and vote or not oh we're still
getting a new mayor what's up stay home
no i'm kidding i'm getting there go out
and vote there's a lot of local things
up on your ballot so get out the vote
um that's our show thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
the monday morning show where we deliver
the fast effect stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast and
we're a podcast we found out spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i heart
radio cast box all the places wait
listen to the podcast find nice morning
toast leave a five-star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are and
if you made it to the end of this
episode congratulations you were part of
the society season two full of real
toasters who actually listened to the
end of the episode we really appreciate
you so to let us know that you are one
of the appreciated ones why don't you
head over to our most recent instagram
and drop an emoji do the emoji there's
that new one with the bandage on it like
that white bandage for all the love lost
between
sarah and john b have a great day i
don't know the emoji but if you don't
know you'll show us yeah bye